we have a big day we're starting it off
with a fantastical breakfast we're about
to go sharpen he's gonna use you as bait
what you're doing cleaning I'm preparing
for the shark so I can see them clearly
this shucks around look at this is
Kanaka the case this is a perfect omelet
it's real it's real is it real it's
beautiful
okay on the other side of the aisle
little we are look how look like we are
so insignificant in life and this map is
showing us a millionaire
[Music]
[Applause]
you ready for this Jim because the boat
is arriving this was on my bucket list
yeah I don't have one I don't either but
I think this would have been on if I did
that one well now you have one oh you
can and then maybe next year I can do we
get scuba certified you real-life scuba
certification I think is difficult what
are you doing what tell me what you're
doing I mean I'm really busy
you know that one's done all right these
people just got off the boat we're about
to go into our own shark encounter
[Music]
we just arrived at the cage destination
I like this so excited
[Music]
[Applause]
all right bar sharks I was so successful
there's so many shark I'm so short out
right now
[Music]
didn't even blog after I got off the
boat because I was seriously in such
shock at what we just did and it was so
much fun to tell me what are you feeling
right now it was insane
the only thing was like getting beat
around by the way it's kind of art yeah
against what the sharks don't even care
about you well I like oh are you here we
don't care
[Music]